bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regardant
direct ravi de vous retrouver
l'actualité à l'Assemblée ce soir c'est
ce dérapage juger raciste à la fin des
questions au gouvernement le député du
rassemblement national Grégoire de
Fournas a provoqué une interruption
rarissime de séances en cause ces propos
à l'adresse de Carlos Martin bilongo de
la France insoumise qui s'exprimait sur
les migrants qu'il retourne en Afrique
annoncé le député du RN l'assemblée
convoque son bureau demain pour décider
d'éventuelles sanctions la France
insoumise mais aussi la majorité
macroniste refuse de siéger tant que ce
député n'est pas exclu on va revenir
dans le détail sur ce qui s'est passé
dans l'hémicycle la normalisation du RN
a-t-elle touché ses limites à deux jours
du congrès du parti grand débat dans un
instant sur ce plateau notre grand
témoin ce soir est à la fois historien
éditeur documentariste et théologien il
vient publier la crucifixion de
l'Ukraine Milan de guerre de religion en
Europe chez Albin Michel ouvrage qui
pose la question majeure des origines
historiques du conflit en U
Jean-François colossimo est avec nous ce
soir enfin deux parties pris deux
affranchis ce soir on va accueillir un
nouveau visage l'avocat Bertrand Perrier
qui reviendra sur cette histoire
saugrenue de nouveaux pays qui a
enflammé la toile et puis Yanis roder et
ses histoires d'école ce soir le 49-3
expliquez au collégiens voilà pour le
programme c'est vert c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est sans doute le moment le plus tendu
depuis le début de cette nouvelle
législature et on va s'y arrêter dans le
détail en longueur ce soir bonsoir
Sylvain Maillard et merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation députée
renaissance de Paris bonsoir
Jean-Philippe Tanguy bonsoir merci à
vous d'être là vous êtes député
rassemblement national de la Somme
bonsoir Nadège à Beaumont gollumi un bon
Mongolie pardonnez-moi je corrige
immédiatement fait un père député la
France insoumise de scène Saint-Denis et
puis la journaliste à l'Obs
éditorialiste à lobs Carole Barjon va
nous rejoindre dans un tout petit
instant mais celle qui va nous refaire
le film de ce qui s'est passé vous allez
voir c'était électrique ce soir c'est
Stéphanie Despierres si j'ai bien
compris son billet tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane ici bonsoir bienvenue
si j'ai bien compris ce soir si j'ai
bien compris ce soir il y a eu des
propos racistes proférés dans
l'hémicycle alors il était 16h46 à 15
minutes avant la fin des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement vous le
savez ça se déroule toutes les semaines
à l'Assemblée tout était calme un peu
d'ennuis pointait sur les bancs et puis
le député insoumis Carlos Martin bilongo
s'inquiète dans une question du sort de
234 migrants bloqués en Méditerranée à
bord d'un navire du ONG qui ne peut
accoster sur aucune côte ni en Italie ni
ailleurs et puis soudain au milieu de sa
question un autre député l'interpelle
tant de l'oreille les personnes
secourues se trouvent dans une situation
d'urgence absolue des prévisions météo
indiquent une décoration significative
du climat
pas du tout
c'est
[Applaudissements]
quel est le député qui vient de
prononcer cette phrase
pardon
flotte la présidente de l'Assemblée
chercha
identifier le député qui a prononcé
cette phrase qu'il retourne en Afrique
c'est difficile d'entendre dans le
brouhaha de l'hémicycle qui a crié cette
phrase et mais tous les députés semblent
avoir bien entendu regarder ça se lit
sur les visages notamment sur le visage
du voisin du député Carlos Martin
bilongo alors la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale suspend vous le
voyez on voit regarder vous allez voir
sur cette image la stupeur en fait sur
les visages et la présidente de
l'Assemblée suspend brièvement la séance
c'est déjà rare et encore plus rare 5
minutes plus tard quand elle revient
elle met carrément faim à cette séance
de questions d'actualité au Gouvernement
regardez je vous propose compte tenu de
l'émotion légitime qui s'est emparée de
l'ensemble des membres de assemblées et
de l'ensemble du gouvernement de
suspendre la séance de questions au
gouvernement
mon bureau alors on le voit tous les
groupes quittent l'hémicycle qui a
prononcé cette phrase la question alors
après quelques minutes de flottement on
apprend que c'est le député du
rassemblement national à Grégoire de
Fournas qui a interrompu le député
insoumis et qui a crié qu'il retourne en
Afrique alors parlait-il des migrants ou
du députés Carlos Martins Bilingo
s'estime viser et dénonce immédiatement
des propos racistes
nationale vous allez me faire insulter
en m'insulter moi et toutes les
personnes qui sont en France et ils ont
ta couleur de peau et c'est tellement
triste d'arriver à être en novembre
depuis quatre mois nous soyons ici et on
voit la vraie phase de rassemblement
national c'est honteux c'est
complètement honteux d'être envoyé à sa
couleur de peau aujourd'hui
alors après plusieurs ministres minutes
pardon de silence radio du côté du
rassemblement national Grégoire de
Fournas vient s'expliquer aux quatre
colonnes il explique que on a mal
compris ces propos notamment du côté des
insoumis quand le député de la France
insoumise parler du bateau SOS
Méditerranée qui ne parvenait pas à
accoster sur les côtes européennes j'y
répondu qu'il retourne en Afrique je
parlais du bateau pasteur de migrants
voilà que les choses soient très claires
nous sommes en phase une manipulation de
la France insoumise qui cherche à
dénaturer mes propos pour me faire tenir
des propos dégueulasses vis-à-vis d'un
collègue député député français de la
nation qui a la même légitimité que moi
si j'ai dans ces bancs
alors cet incident à soulever beaucoup
des mois surtout les bons le camp
présidentiel lui dénonce l'inacceptable
ce qui s'est passé tout à l'heure au
sein de l'hémicycle et juste
inacceptible inacceptable c'est une
attitude
infâme infâme dire dans cette émission
de l'Assemblée nationale on puisse
encore avoir des propos aussi racistes
le vernis tente craquer tout simplement
c'est ça le rassemblement national même
la présidente de l'Assemblée vient
s'expliquer
il y a les rappels à l'ordre et rappelle
alors avec inscriptions procès-verbal
qui va le sanction financière et puis il
y a après des exclusions une au-delà
l'ascension de l'exclusion donc c'est ce
sont des sanctions qui peuvent être
prononcées par le Bureau donc je ne vais
pas
préjugés d'ores et déjà de la décision
du bureau mais la situation est
suffisamment grave pour que nous
puissions nous réunir rapidement alors
vous l'avez entendu il y a le Braun
Pivet à égrainer les types de sanctions
possibles à l'encontre de ce député du
rassemblement national alors les
insoumis réclament la plus forte ça
s'appelle la censure avec exclusion on
est privé pendant deux mois de la moitié
de son indemnité et avec l'interdiction
de paraître dans l'enceinte du Palais
Bourbon et de participer au débat
pendant deux semaines alors sanction ou
pas à quel niveau la décision sera prise
demain début d'après-midi ce qu'on
appelle le bureau de l'Assemblée se
réunit à 14h30 merci beaucoup merci pour
tous ces détails Stéphanie on va
reprendre dans l'ordre il y a beaucoup
de sujets je vais tout simplement vous
demander comment vous avez réagi
qu'est-ce que vous avez
ressenti après cette phrase et vous nous
en donnerez chacun interprétation on va
commencer par Madame on va on va on va
dans l'ordre monsieur Tanguy s'il vous
plaît c'est moi qui décide à qui je
m'adresse dans ce débat au premier
Nadège à Beaumont vous êtes de la France
insoumise c'est un de vos collègues dans
votre groupe qui a l'adresse de qui
s'est adressé cette phrase des bancs du
rassemblement national qu'avez-vous
ressenti d'abord moi je tiens d'abord à
dire deux choses la première c'est que
dans l'hémicycle tout le monde a entendu
ce qui a été prononcé d'accord donc là
on parle de propos jugés racistes je
pense que Monsieur Maillard le
confirmera monsieur Marleix qui était à
proximité des bancs là entendu également
ce qui a été dit c'est retourne en
Afrique donc
première chose deuxième chose c'est que
j'ai hésité à venir parce que depuis
tout à l'heure moi je suis dans un état
même physique assez difficile et je
tiens à dire que dans l'hémicycle j'ai
pleuré
non pas parce que je suis une personne
faible mais parce qu'à travers Carlos
Matar bilan Go en fait des milliers de
personnes des millions de personnes ont
été insultées des millions de personnes
ont été ramenées alors couleur de peau
des milliers de personnes voulaient
parcours et les vies en France sont
admirables ont été insultés Carlos ce
matin il est décuté de la nation depuis
le mois de juillet il siège il travaille
il a son travail de parlementaire sur sa
circonscription à mener et là
aujourd'hui on est amené à débattre de
cela et c'est ça qui est difficile à
encaisser en fait en tout cas merci
d'être là et merci de participer à ce
débat Sylvain Maillard qu'avez-vous
ressenti il y a effectivement un besoin
de clarification sur la phrase mais on
est dans le cadre de l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale il faut dire les
choses un député de couleur noire le mot
Afrique retournait en Afrique ce sont
des mots qui ont été prononcés le sens
des mots compte mais il renvoie aussi un
imaginaire il renvoie une histoire
qu'avez-vous ressenti
à une profonde honte profondeur honte au
fond d'un
hurlement d'un député qui au fond de lui
a dit ce qu'il pensait il avait en face
de lui un député de un député d'abord
qui exprimait sur un drame humain qu'on
soit quoi qu'on en pense un drame humain
avec des gens abordent d'un bateau et il
dit Ben qui retourne en Afrique et moi
ce député je vous avoue je le
connaissais pas mais quand on regarde un
peu ses propos moi je regarde juste un
peu un autre tweet de 2019
il y a tout un truc si on peut le
retrouver c'est du 17 09 2019 si Erwan
veut être avec des Noirs il peut aller
en Afrique ça c'est sur son Twitter
c'est une obsession et j'en ai deux
comme ça donc on voit très clairement on
peut
ergoter sur qu'est-ce qu'il a dit
exactement à ce que le mot très
clairement c'est un propos raciste qui
doit être condamné moi je demande à ce
que Marine Le Pen qui est président de
ce groupe le con et qu'elle fasse des
excuses pour son député parce que il y a
une chose qui m'a choqué et Monsieur
Tanguy qui était avec moi à ce moment-là
ou un moment très physique dans
l'assemblée moi j'ai demandé à ce que ce
député sorte de l'assemblée il était là
et je lui ai demandé d'ailleurs c'est
Tanguy et à Monsieur Chenu faites le
sortir qu'on puisse continuer il y aura
une sanction ensuite mais qu'on puisse
continuer qu'il sorte non non non non
non non non non non il est hors de
question sortir c'est vous qui sortez
mais vous avez jamais dit sortez je suis
d'accord vous avez raison mais la
discussion c'est est-ce que nous sortons
déjà et donc moi c'est très simple je
demande des excuses au rassemblement
national parce que pour moi vous avez
protégé ce député là alors qu'il y avait
il fallait le sortir immédiatement vous
allez protéger et vous vous mettez dans
des situations qui est je pense pour
vous qui au fond où vous dit
profondément ce que vous êtes je parle
du rassemblement ça je parle pas de vous
rassemblement national ce que vous êtes
en le protégeant ou bien au fond bah ses
propos ça ne vous choque pas si
fortement que ça ce soir Grégoire de
Fournas estime on l'a entendu qu'il est
victime d'une manipulation et que qu'il
retourne en Afrique alors il a commencé
son entourage a commencé à parler de la
question de il d'entourage l'URL les
migrants et puis un tout petit peu après
y compris il a dit très clairement qu'il
s'agissait des bateaux pour vous ça
n'est que de la manipulation il y a pas
quelque chose qui vous choque dans ces
propos là vous personnellement non mais
si
vous avez entendu ce que vous pensez
avoir entendu comprendre c'est choqué
mais ce n'est pas la phrase qui a été
prononcée madame
donc tout le monde ment tout le monde
est complotiste en fait tout le monde
invente le plaisir de rapporter ses
propos ce n'est pas un plaisir si c'est
les propos que vous avez ce que vous
auriez entendu oui mais ce n'est pas ce
qui a été dit et d'ailleurs on en est à
la troisième phrase d'accord au début
moi je suis derrière monsieur de
fournade il a dit qu'il retourne en
Afrique il a pas dit retourne en Afrique
ce que vous avez dit Madame au début
mais même qu'il retourne en Afrique sauf
que d'accord sauf qu'à un moment faut
établir l'effet d'accord
c'est comme au début vous dites il y a
dérapage donc déjà de toute façon déjà
vous partez juste que vous avez deux
débuts par la grande majorité
c'est le titre de votre émission dès que
déjà vous avez été que c'était un
dérapage juger raciste par les députés
de le fait que vous qualifier ça
dérapage donc déjà il y a un parti pris
dans cette émission visiblement bon il y
a eu trois versions en une heure on est
parti de il a dit à notre collègue mais
si c'est ce que vous venez de dire
Madame retourne en Afrique après
finalement c'est qu'il retourne en
Afrique en se demandant ah bah parce que
on a eu trois versions et d'ailleurs
même à la fin les insoumis on dit et
vous venez le dire aussi
excusez-moi il y a deux éléments dans
cette affaire le premier il a été dit
retourne en Afrique et le deuxième
élément c'est la la ligne de défense
lâche parce que ce sont des propos qui
ne sont pas assumés de votre collègue
non madame c'est ce qu'il a dit depuis
le début c'est ce qu'il a dit depuis le
début évidemment
il est hors de question que ce député
s'excuse pour recevoir
ne serait-ce qu'une maladie
j'ai dit si sortir serait reconnaître ce
que disent la fin insomnie ce qu'il faut
on va quand même pas reconnaître un
mensonge donc pour vous j'ai demandé
parce que
oui et je vais vous dire pourquoi enfin
il y a eu un emballement irrationnel
c'est du jamais vu les missiles
irrationnels j'ai demandé à la
présidente PV quand j'ai accompagné
monsieur Fournas
qu'est-ce qu'avait entendu les huissiers
et qu'est-ce qu'elle avait entendu les
sténos qui font confondues séances j'ai
demandé et là Monsieur
de séance personne n'a voulu nous dire
qu'avait dit qu'on entendu de séance on
a dû attendre que votre votre chaîne
fasse des tweets pour dire le
compte-rendu de séance donne enfin vous
avez pas dit bonne raison mais dit qu'il
reparte en Afrique au pluriel donc le
compte rendu de séance donne la version
que nous avons donné donne la version
que nous avons donné depuis le début
qu'il au pluriel renvoie à qui renvoie
au bateau aux migrants mais les migrants
sont sur les bateaux donc le débat entre
savoir c'est les bateaux et les migrants
et de mauvaise foi on parlait on parlait
d'un bateau dans la question de SOS
Méditerranée en l'occurrence ce bateau
là bon c'est très clair vous avez
totalement le droit de vous défendre il
n'y a aucun parti pris la vérité vous
expliquer
des faits parce que moi au début au nom
du groupe parce que remplacer Marine Le
Pen je descends et je dis qu'est-ce que
ils ont entendu qu'est-ce qui a été dit
dans le compte rendu on refuse cela et
donc on glose pendant une heure qui
refuse cela et le l'ensemble des
personnes présentes à nous refuse qu'on
regarde le contrôle
dit ce que madame a entendu voilà donc
donc
tout ça n'aurait pas existé si on avait
regardé de compte-rendu de séance mais
pas sur la table
c'est pas la phrase qui est de toute
façon qu'il retourne en Afrique de toute
façon c'est parce que c'est pas pour ça
que vous êtes descendu monsieur Maya
vous êtes descendu parce que vous avez
dit il a dit retourne en Afrique donc
faut savoir soit vous êtes descendu vous
êtes indignés sur une phrase qui a été
prononcée soit elle n'a pas été
prononcée la phrase qu'il retourne en
Afrique m'indique tout autant non mais
ça c'est maintenant qu'il m'a dit n'est
pas publié
et c'est quand même c'est quand même un
député qui a un vrai un vrai souci
vous montrer à quel point vous défendez
l'indéfendable monsieur tomber je
défends le 2 22 octobre c'est public 22
octobre 2017 en Afrique virgule c'est ce
même député ils aiment tous la France et
ses allocs on accueille toute l'Afrique
c'est une obsession il a cette obsession
mais là vous êtes en train de ressortir
des trucs
comme session de demande qui a plus de
vous vous ne devez pas vous vous ne
devez pas dépendre
c'est un digne de défenseur
on apprend que votre collège de Fournas
a envoyé un mail à votre collègue Martin
bilongo je ne connais pas la nature du
contenu de ce message et si on le sait
on le donnera en direct évidemment
bonsoir Carole barjot et merci
infiniment de participer à ce débat vous
êtes éditorialiste à l'Obs il y a les
mots prononcés et puis il y a la
perception et la manière dont ils sont
reçus et en politique la perception
c'est très important à quoi a-t-on
résister selon vous quel mot
placer est-ce que c'est un incident
est-ce que c'est un dérapage je pose la
question Jean-Philippe c'est une
question comment voyez-vous les choses
ça c'est pas ça c'est pas à moi de le
dire pardon mais il y a ou bien parce
que il y a pas de caractère judiciaire
qui peut être un criminé puisque on est
au sein de l'hémicycle et qu'au sein de
l'hémicycle c'est effectué ce sont les
instances internes à l'Assemblée
nationale la présidente qui va réunir le
bureau demain avec les vice-présidents
etc qui prendront ou non la décision
d'une sanction et il y aura évidemment
tous les représentants de de toutes les
étiquettes
politiques pour dire si c'est un
dérapage bon ça c'est en tout cas oui ça
c'est un incident ça c'est sûr
j'apprends ce soir en même temps que je
vous parle que dans ce mail il exprime
des regrets il dit qu'il est navré de
l'incompréhension que ses propos ont
suscité mais ils formule pas d'excuses
c'est ce qu'il a déjà dit on l'a vu tout
à l'heure les images c'est ce qu'il a
déjà dit quand les journalistes
l'intergaient à la sortie de l'hémicycle
il a expliqué non je parlais des bateaux
des migrants etc voilà il a pas formé
plus dis donc en envoyant une forme de
signaler de maladresse ou bien sûr
notre collègue mais comme je le suis
navré je voulais d'un truc sur madame je
suis sincère je suis navré si vous avez
entendu ça et que ça va ça vous a créé
une émotion et tu le respect que cette
émotion je suis pas du tout un train de
sous-estimer même pas personnel en
réalité très bien Madame mais
seulement personnel en fait j'ai une
question mais vous avez souligné cette
question
cet incident est quand même
regrettable pour le rassemblement
national parce que depuis que il a
obtenu 89 députés ce qui est énorme à
l'Assemblée nationale on a bien vu que
Marine Le Pen on a appelé ça la
stratégie de la cravate poursuit son
entreprise de respectabilité
en vue de la présidentielle de 2025 donc
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est sans se
faire juger
ça tombe assez mal et et c'est vrai que
voilà au moins politiquement monsieur ce
monsieur de Fournas aurait peut-être dû
surveiller son langage ça c'est certain
on va revenir sur cette stratégie de la
normalisation dont vous êtes un peu
l'emblème si je puis dire mais
Jean-Philippe simplement je voudrais je
voudrais si vous le permettez tout à
l'heure il y a eu des mots sur la
question de savoir si même il s'agissait
des bateaux peut-être des vacances
je vous pose cette question parce que
c'est intéressant ça renvoie au passé
s'il s'agissait des migrants ou s'il
s'agissait des bateaux ces propos
seraient-il déjà raciste ça nous renvoie
ça c'est déjà des mots qui ont été
prononcés figurez-vous par Chantal
Brunel je ne sais pas si vous vous
rappelez de Chantal Brunel elle était
député les républicains sous le
quinquennat de Nicolas Sarkozy on va
l'écouter
on ne rassure pas les Français aussi sur
toutes les populations qui viennent des
de la Méditerranée après tout
remettons-les dans les bâtons voilà 2011
Jean-Philippe Tanguy oui c'était le
remettre sur des embarcations qui
étaient dangereuses on n'a pas dit qu'il
fallait remettre et la polémique avait
été gigantesque
j'en souviens très bien qu'il fallait
remettre des personnes menacées sur un
bateau qui était dangereux sur les
bateaux dangereux donc ça me dit qu'il
fallait remettre les migrants dans des
bateaux dangereux on a dit que le bateau
ne devait pas aller sur les ports
européens mais sur les ports africains
ça a toujours été la position constante
du rêve et aussi de LR même si
aujourd'hui
ça se comprend de façon aussi
les migrants doivent être emmenés dans
les ports d'origine qui sont en
l'occurrence en Afrique c'est la
position du règne donc en fait
maintenant on est passé d'une polémique
qui n'est donc pas de lieu d'être sur
des propos soit disant racistes à au
procès de notre position sur le sur le
mais moi je veux
vous savez il y a eu plusieurs incidents
dans cette assemblée et là visiblement
il y avait l'indignation sélective on
est monsieur ribeirotte qui a fait un
salut nazi et des moustaches nazis en
plein en pleine séance on vous a pas vu
lever quitter l'hémicycle il a mis en
cause des députés en disant que c'est
nous qui avons fait le salut lundi c'est
lui qui l'avait fait qu'est-ce qu'il a
eu rien du tout monsieur Prady non non
monsieur pratique
a fait une connexion pour vous qui
n'était pas entre c'est pas l'acheter
on a tenu aucun propos
il a été sanctionné il a été sanctionné
il a été désolidarisé
nous et voilà apparenté et on l'a
apparenté du groupe est-ce qu'il a eu
comme sanction il a été convoqué devant
le bureau il a dû s'expliquer j'étais
présent de de
convoqué devant il a eu le bureau et je
crois que personne dans l'hémicycle
aucun d'entre nous n'est allé défendre
sur les plateaux Télévisions en disant
mais sinon
c'était pas oui mais nous moi moi je
suis une très claire en disant je vois
la différence en disant un geste qui est
inacceptable et je le redis sur cette
antenne et un propos raciste que vous
essayez de de de de de démonter ou
d'atténuer moi j'assume
qu'un député
vous ne l'assumez pas au fond ça remet
en cause monsieur
Ribe personne peut dire que c'est pas un
salut nazi
arrêtez
c'est pareil
c'est absolument pas mais c'est pas du
tout encore diversion mais il y a pas
une personne en France
vous vouliez mais retourne en Afrique à
10h en fait vous vous estimez victime
bien sûr
évidemment que c'est une un procès qui
est fort assemblée depuis quatre mois et
donc là maintenant on verra demain quels
sont les sanctions qui sont prises on
regarde du compte-rendu et au regard des
enregistrements ce qui est vrai et vous
avez montré rappeler les propos
qu'avaient tenu Chantal Brunel c'est une
position constante de ceux qui pensent
qu'il faut non seulement maîtriser les
flux migratoires mais éventuellement
même fermer carrément les frontières
simplement très souvent c'est dit tout à
fait autrement
généralement on dit de manière beaucoup
plus châtier ces gens ont voc à
retourner dans leur pays c'est quand
même généralement la formule consacrée
là on est dans une autre formulation qui
effectivement est choquante alors
j'aimerais savoir
on a le droit d'avoir la différence
politique sur la sur la politique
migrale tout à fait mais c'est raciste
de dire à des bateaux contents des
migrants
qui parle de de bateau en détresse en
pleine mer en réalité depuis tout à
l'heure vous faites diversion monsieur
il faut aucune diversion Adams il faut
qu'il y avait refusé que je parle tout à
l'heure
visiblement vous avez vous avez le droit
de communiquer ce député qui en
permanence
ça veut dire vous avez respecté j'ai
respecté votre émotion tout à l'heure
madame vous n'avez pas laissé vous
n'avez pas laissé respecter le bien
parce que moi aussi quand monsieur
pradiatique vous êtes heurté en fait
vous êtes heurté le retournement du
stigmate
votre émotion vous ne respectez pas la
mienne et vous m'avez pas laissé parler
de l'émotion que moi j'ai pas eu le
droit de ressentir les émotions comme
Monsieur Pradier machine analyse très
forte
madame et je la finirai vous ne voulez
pas que moi je n'ai pas le droit d'avoir
d'émotion quand monsieur Pradier comme
Monsieur Pradier a fait un lien entre la
variole du singe et les homosexuels j'ai
pas le droit d'avoir d'émotions
vous avez ce sujet là en fait là on
essaie de rester sur cette phrase ce
soir
du bureau il doit y avoir des sanctions
demain et est-ce qu'on peut être même
voilà historique puisque ce qui m'a
surpris c'est de voir immédiatement le
groupe Renaissance a fait corps avec la
nupesse et vous avez dit on ne
ressergera pas tant que les sanctions et
des sanctions lourdes ne sont pas prises
à l'égard de Grégoire de Fourneuf
coupable avant le process cette décision
elle était évidente oui évidente nous
avons demandé ce qui est immédiatement
ce député sorte de l'hémicycle on était
en pleine question au gouvernement il y
avait encore certains députés qui
devaient poser des questions et on a
demandé à ce qui sortent dans
l'hémicycle et à ce moment-là certains
députés de la France insoumise on s'en
va on s'en va tous et nous avons décidé
et je redis personne ne sort de cette
émission c'est pas nous de sortir de
cette émission c'est à lui de sortir de
ses mystique et c'est au moment où j'ai
eu la discussion avec Monsieur Tanguy et
Monsieur Chenon sortez-le de l'hémicycle
vous attendez quoi une exclusion du
groupe nous on va on va plaider on va
plaider je demande des excuses à Marine
Le Pen il y aura pas du groupe sur sur
cet acte et qui est des sanctions
lourdes très lourdes les sanctions les
plus fortes envers ce député demain en
bureau des présidents je ferais parti de
ceux qui siège alors on va en plus de ça
en plus de cela moi je voudrais rajouter
une chose en plus de cela je voudrais
ajouter également le fait que depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
plusieurs années un certain nombre de
personnes qui interviennent dans des bas
publics mettent un signe égal entre le
rassemblement national et la France
insoumise j'aimerais peut-être que à
partir de ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
ces gens là cessent parce que la
banalisation du RN avec la comparaison
avec 20 sens unique est insupportable et
ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui la
démontrer Carole Barjon il y a de
l'émotion de l'indignation il y a aussi
de la politique dans ce débat il faut le
dire il y a de la tactique par exemple
demain motion de censure sur le budget
déposé par elle est fi pas d'émotion
déposées par l'URL qui avait dit qui
voterait cette motion avec elle est fit
et la nuit pèse semble compliqué
Carole bah oui là on comprendrait pas
très bien honnêtement parce que là ces
deux groupes s'opposent de manière
extrêmement violente
on comprendrait pas très bien ensuite
alors ce sera une un autre sujet mais
oui c'est intéressant d'avoir votre
réponse
[Musique]
ce soir oui je la vois à titre personnel
les filles ou n'importe qui qui la pose
d'ailleurs la mousse en censure n'est
pas un contrat de gouvernement
absolument mais ça 89 députés nationales
dans un scrutin qui lui est
traditionnellement pas favorable le RN a
réussi à un exploit électoral à cette
dernière législative Marine Le Pen a
abandonné la tête du parti pour piloter
ce groupe de députés pour la plupart
novice normalisé institutionnalisés le
temps du RN plutôt du FN des années 80
balayer l'avant l'après en question
c'est signé Clément Méric
en 1986 pour la première fois le Front
National et Jean-Marie Le Pen entre à
l'Assemblée nationale et voilà ce que ça
donne Françoise de panafieux député RPR
et même violemment prise à partie
effectivement un député du Front
national a bousculé à Madame de panacieu
ce qui est tout à fait scandaleux
insulte grossière demande de suspension
de séance condamnation de l'absentéisme
parlementaire et surtout démarche
exceptionnelles deux députés du Front
national vont monter à la tribune
derrière le président de séance pour
surveiller le déroulement de la
procédure
seulement seul le président de la parole
s'il vous plaît puis les amis de
Monsieur Le Pen courent dans les travées
et vote à la place des députés absents
un vol de scrutin aujourd'hui 35 ans
plus tard le contraste est saisissant
tiré à quatre épingles 89 députés du
rassemblement national font leur entrée
à l'Assemblée la consigne a été donnée
par les chefs du groupe tenus correct
exigé la stratégie de la cravate a
remplacé celle du coup d'éclat merci
madame la Présidente sur le fond sur le
fond
après des années à se présenter en
partie anti-système le RN veut démontrer
sa crédibilité vous l'avez compris nous
ne souhaitons pas être une opposition
d'obstruction mais de propositions pas
une opposition de principe il se battent
pour obtenir un maximum de postes au
Palais Bourbon première bataille les
vice-présidents elles doivent refléter
la composition de l'Assemblée avec 89
députés le RN peut accéder grâce aux
voix macronistes il en obtient 2
monsieur Sébastien Chenu et Madame
Hélène Laporte deuxième bataille perdue
celle-là la présidence de la commission
des finances c'est l'insoumi Éric
Coquerel qui a été élu le RN visait
désormais plusieurs présidents de
groupes d'amitié mais l'incident survenu
aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle vient
court-circuiter cette stratégie de
normalisation aujourd'hui l'extrême
droite a montré son vrai visage ce que
nous disons depuis des années sur le
rassemblement national le Front national
avant et bien bien de s'exprimer de
manière complètement libre dans
l'assemblée les députés de la nuque
réclament désormais l'exclusion
temporaire du député RN Grégoire de
Fournas une sanction rarissime à
l'Assemblée
croyez-vous franchement Sylvain Maillard
que ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui va
avoir des conséquences politiques sur
les électeurs est-ce que au contraire ça
ne profite pas aussi au rassemblement
national que de le pointer du doigt
systématiquement si des propos racistes
sont tenus au sein de l'hémicycle et que
ça profite au rassemblement national les
bras mentons je crois qu'il y a un
moment où très clairement dans quand il
y a un propos raciste qui est tenu
c'est normal pour la représentation
nationale mon importe quel citoyen de se
dresser de dire que c'est inacceptable
que ce soit dans cette hémicy car
effectivement
il peut y avoir moins des sanctions et
nous voulons être sanctions non il a pas
changé il y a un nouvel habillage il y a
une mais il y a un fond il y a un fond
moi je suis très surpris qu'en fait que
pour être honnête avec vous je suis très
surpris que Monsieur Tanguy
essaye de protéger l'un des siens dans
un moment où il me semble que au
contraire et il a la plus intérêt à
vraiment le sanctionner je suis assez
surpris là-dessus et de défendre que
cette phrase ou ce contexte ne serait
pas raciste avec encore une fois le
contexte de ce député qui a l'air bien
connu et donc je ne comprends pas ça
j'espère que oui aussi les électeurs
entendront ça que voilà
je vous donne la parole dans un instant
Carole Barjon mais non on peut pas dire
que le rassemblement national c'est la
même chose que le Front national d'avant
c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait faux
il a changé sur le fond il a abandonné
la sortie de l'euro
qu'il préconisait Marine Le Pen
elle-même l'abandonné elle s'est
dissocier de son père qui était un ultra
libéral et elle elle s'est préoccupait
beaucoup plus de questions sociales
je vous rappelle je vous rappelle aussi
je ne suis pas là pour défendre le
rassemblement national non mais juste
pour dire que s'il y a 41% de Français
qui lui donne leur vote au second tour
ça veut dire quelque chose et donc
effectivement elle n'est plus aussi
marginale que les gens Marie Le Pen ou
qui voulaient supprimer carrément
l'impôt enfin qui faisait des tas de
jeux de mots souvenez-vous du rapport
crématoire le les fours comme matoires
qui étaient un détail de l'histoire et
cetera elle s'est démarquée de tout ça
donc on peut pas dire que ce sont les
mêmes qu'il reste un son ça oui bien
entendu de la même manière je ne sais
plus quel ça veut dire un feu que je ne
sais plus retourner nationale d'accord
au RPR qu'on trouvait le maximum de
gaullistes oui
au rassemblement national il y a aussi
des anciens du Front national bon voilà
mais on peut pas dire que comme Marine
Le Pen n'a pas changé que leur
assemblement national et le même que
du fnorl le nom change mais les
références si deux et les habitudes
ignobles restent qu'à le monde
monsieur Macron avait des Mayotte avait
fait des blagues absolument ignobles sur
les quoi ça quoi ça bon on n'avait pas
entendu monsieur Darmanin sophusqué de
ça ce qui était pour le coup une blague
totalement raciste donc en fait tout le
monde se jette ce soir sur une histoire
qui le rappelle les mensongères et qui
n'a pas lieu d'être pour faire son
procès rassemblement national puisque
ils ont absolument rien d'autre à dire
juste dire parce que tout à l'heure j'ai
pas pu dire ce que je voulais dire
Madame Bron Pivet qu'elle est présente
de séance en sortant sur votre antenne a
dit la chose suivante que elle a
elle-même dit entendu retourne en
Afrique mais elle précise que la
question qui se pose demain parce que
visiblement monsieur Maria nous a
condamné avant même qu'il bureau que la
question qui se posera demain au bureau
et de savoir si c'est retour en Afrique
ou qu'il retourne en Afrique nous allons
pouvoir établir la matérialité des faits
donc non non donc la présence de séance
a dit que la question de demain c'est de
savoir l'effet qui sont passés c'est
pour ça que j'ai assisté sur ce qui
s'est passé vraiment voilà donc
maintenant moi je veux bien les règles
article et les députés ne peuvent pas
porter plainte donc la question de
l'interprétation
du bureau qui a une sorte de place de
juge dans cette affaire et très
importantes demain mais apparemment il y
a un compte-rendu d'après ce que vous
disiez il y a déjà un compte rendu oui
il y a un compte-rendu la première
version qui nous a été dite et dire que
le compte-rendu disait confirmé
m'avertissement
alors manifestement c'était une erreur
de notre part
n'existe pas excusez-moi est-ce que
c'est normal 20h c'était à quelle heure
16h46 est-ce que c'est normal que 3
heures après on sache pas quel est le
compte-rendu on va coûter on te marche
sur la tête donc on voit bien que là
rien ne fonctionne le compte-rendu c'est
le service de la séance
a peut-être pas bien entendu
mais ok
mais vous avez une très bonne idée
qu'il retourne en Afrique
au début j'avais pas entendu ça quand
j'ai réécoutais la vidéo c'était très
clair qui enfin en tout cas ce que j'ai
entendu qu'il retourne en Afrique donc
c'est pas ce qu'a dit Madame mais c'est
tout aussi n'importe quoi
on va terminer ce débat et on attendra
de voir demain quel sera retourne en
Afrique et dire que les bateaux ont un
truc c'est pas pareil
et pour le RN qui est supposé être très
soucieux d'images de la France en fait
là ce soir on voit que quand même c'est
assez déplorable vous imaginez les
images qui tournent qui peuvent tourner
en fait pour la France mais c'est vrai
que c'est assez pitoyable et pour
répondre à votre question
parce que c'est au rassemblement
national je ne le crois pas du tout pas
du tout pas du tout puisque c'est
totalement national
qui au fond de de pas faire de
dernière précision s'il vient Maillard
[Musique]
rendez-vous demain soir sur SCP bien sûr
19h30 on vous réexpliquera et on vous
donnera cette décision et vous la
pourrez la commenter et réagir merci
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé tous
les quatre à se débat on va accueillir à
présent notre grand témoin il est à la
fois historien éditeur documentariste et
théologien il vient de publier la
crucifixion de l'Ukraine quel titre il
va nous l'expliquer 1000 ans de guerre
de religion en Europe chez Albin Michel
ouvrage qui pose la question majeur d'où
vient ce conflit en Ukraine donc
François Colombie nous nous rejoint
juste après l'invitation signé ce soir
par Marion Becker
si on vous invite Jean-François
colossimo c'est pour revenir à la genèse
de cette guerre en Ukraine pour
comprendre un conflit en apparence
incompréhensible impensable
vous l'expliquez par la dimension
religieuse dans votre dernier livre la
crucifixion de l'Ukraine Milan de guerre
religieuse en Europe car Jean-François
colossimo vous êtes historien théologien
spécialiste du monde orthodoxe dans vos
ouvrages vous scrutez la présence du
religieux dans nos sociétés comme dans
l'Apocalypse russe ou la religion
française cette fois vous retracez 1000
ans de guerre de religion en Europe et
vous expliquer comment l'Ukraine cette
terre centrale est un enjeu majeur dans
les guerres saintes comment elle a été
écartelée entre les empires européens
nous l'avons oublié n'est-ce pas mais à
la partition entre l'Europe de l'Est et
l'Europe de l'Ouest elle compte à peu
près au 8ème 9ème siècle les
missionnaires Carolingiens les
missionnaires de Charlemagne et
missionnaires Byzantins les
missionnaires Grecs et atteints vont se
confronter pour l'évangélisation des
Slaves sur une ligne de fracture qui
court de Riga
dans les pays baltes à Split aujourd'hui
en Croatie de la mer Baltique à la mer
Méditerranée et cette ligne elle coupe
le crâne en deux l'Ukraine métabolisme
le destin de l'Europe pour vous
Jean-François colossimo cette guerre ce
sont ces deux Europe qui s'affrontent
cette antagonisme cultuel et culturel
instrumentalisées par Vladimir Poutine
pour justifier sa guerre le président
russe invoque la religion s'estime
investi d'une vocation messianique et
impose sa vision manichéenne du monde où
l'altérité est le mal et le Mal doit
être éradiqué dites-vous et pour cela il
s'est trouvé un allié le patriarche
Kyril le chef de l'Église orthodoxe qui
bénit les soldats
de son devoir alors cette personne a
sans aucun doute commis un acte
équivalent à un sacrifice et donc nous
croyons que ce sacrifice
vous les péchés que cette personne a
commis
sauver l'orthodoxie du reste de
l'univers ce serait la mission que
Vladimir Poutine s'est donné et elle
marque le retour du religieux en
politique pour justifier la guerre
contre l'Occident mais Jean-François
colossimo se religieux avait-il
réellement disparu
bonsoir Jean-François colossijo et merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation partons de ce titre il est
très très fort il interpelle la
crucifixion de l'Ukraine vous auriez pu
dire la destruction mais pas du tout
c'est plus c'est plus subtil que ça
explique-nous ce titre parce que d'abord
la crucifixion c'est un écartellement et
ce pays a été véritablement écartelé il
a été en tiré de tous les côtés il a été
démembré n'est-ce pas comme vous voyez
la position de du Crucifié c'est une
position d'extrême tension où tous les
membres vont craquer en quelque sorte et
l'Ukraine n'a cessé de craquer sous quoi
sous la pression d'Empire qui se disait
tous chrétiens et qui donc avait la
croix pour emblème plus l'Empire ottoman
qui a été musulman mais les autres
empires l'Empire byzantin et le Saint
Empire romain germanique puis plus tard
l'Empire évidemment russe ça risque
peut-être expliquez-nous ce qui est très
intéressant dans le livre c'est que vous
remontez aux origines d'où vient d'où
vient-il ce conflit d'abord ce conflit
suit toute l'histoire de l'Europe
absolument expliquez-nous en quoi
précisément alors si on veut essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe pourquoi
est-ce qu'il y a une robe de l'Est
là-bas une robe de l'Ouest pourquoi
elles sont finalement si jumelles et
pourtant si hostile ou du moins elle se
comprennent si mal pourquoi en fait on
s'insurce de chaque côté comme si à
chaque fois on avait affaire en quelque
sorte un faux frère c'est parce qu'il y
a eu une fracture dans cette Europe et
cette fracture elle advient après la
dislocation de l'empire romain voyez
sous les invasions barbares et puis au
8e siècle
quatre siècles après des avions barbares
on se retrouve en fait avec une partie
occidentale qui est l'empire carolingien
l'Empire
romain d'Orient l'Empire byzantin alors
nous nous pensons que vous voyez
Jérusalem c'est la révélation
Athènes c'est la philosophie Rome c'est
le droit et l'Empire et puis la règle
etc nous pensons que ça arrive
directement avec la chapelle la capitale
de Charlemagne et puis ça ça passe à
Bruxelles on a notre Parlement
aujourd'hui bon ben il y a l'autre
partie de l'Europe parce que ça arrive à
Constantinople aujourd'hui
Istanbul mais qui a été la capitale de
l'Empire byzantin et puis à Moscou la
troisième Rome puisqu'on sentinoble et
la seconde la deuxième
pas la Moscou de Poutine la Moscou de
tchaikov de cetera donc on voit bien
qu'il y a une querelle de filiation
cette graine de filiation elle trouve
son occasion au 8e siècle pour la
conversion des Slaves les slaves sont
apparus ils occupent toutes l'Europe
centrale toute l'Europe orientale il
faut les convertir les évangéliser les
évangéliser on les missionnaires francs
c'est à dire Carolingiens francs
Occident je montre les Byzantins Orient
bon ils vont se confronter sur une ligne
de fracture qui courent de Riga c'est
dans les pays baltes la mer Baltique là
haut à Split en Croatie aujourd'hui la
mer Méditerranée elle zigzagent cette
frontière et puis vous allez trouver à
chaque fois regarder tout en haut vous
avez des Polonais catholiques alphabet
latins et un côté vous avez des
Biélorusses orthodoxes alphabet
cyrillique ce qu'on appelle communément
l'alphabet russe vous descendez tout en
bas vous trouver des Croates catholiques
alphabet latin des Serbes
orthodoxes alphabet cyrillique et la
première guerre après la glaciation
communiste en Europe c'est pas l'Ukraine
c'est la guerre des Balkans c'est la
guerre des choses de la vie or c'est
serbes et ses crottes c'est à peu près
en fait le même peuple la fracture elle
est confessionnelles sur cette fracture
vous avez aussi les checks et les
Slovaques ils arrêtent pas de vouloir se
marier ils arrêtent pas de divorcer
parce que et puis elle traverse
entre un ouest catholique et un est
orthodoxe c'est-à-dire que l'Ukraine
métabolise la division qui court sur
toute l'histoire de l'Europe et qui par
exemple cette division explique par
exemple en 1850 c'était pas il y a 1000
ans la guerre de Crimée ou l'Empire
français l'Empire britannique s'allie
avec l'Empire ottoman pour sa conscience
mais les Britanniques et les Français
vont combattre en Crimée les Russes
n'est ce pas et à Paris l'archevêque qui
s'appelle Monseigneur SIBUR
béni les les troubles napoléoniennes on
leur demandant d'aller extirper le
gisement orthodoxe à Saint-Pétersbourg
son homologue métropolitique en or fait
de même électrocaristes mais évidemment
en leur demandant d'aller extirper le
schisme latin donc vous voyez que cette
histoire là elle est profonde
aujourd'hui Poutine
elle est du côté rue orthodoxe un coup
du côté
austro-hongroise il fallait qu'elle soit
catholique du coup elle repasse côté
Prusse et là c'est protestant donc c'est
dramatique c'est positif
prussien et puis il y a pas que ça il y
a pas que les trois christianisme il y a
l'islam qui est là qui t'a l'islam
endogène très ancien c'est celui des
tatar de Crimée et puis il y a la grande
présence juive du Stetten or
malheureusement
l'Ukraine c'est aussi le pays le lieu
des deux totalitarismes du XXe siècle
Lolo de mort un nom qui commence à
entrer dans dans la grande famille dans
les par sa vie et qui déborde l'Ukraine
mais elle frappe surtout en Ukraine
parce que c'est une société paysanne
villageoise
et puis la joie par balle
l'extermination d'un million Juifs qui
étaient autour de dessin par exemple une
grande ville voilà les fausses communes
et là et là il faut lui dire aussi parce
que c'est la leçon du 20e siècle rien de
ce qui inhumain nous être étrangers nous
sommes toujours capables de basculer
dans les humains là ce sont des
Ukrainiens qui servent de supplétif aux
nazis des Ukrainiens de l'Ouest parce
qu'ils sont occidentaux à manière qu'il
y aura des divisions SS Croates vous
voyez c'est dans ce livre au-delà de
montrer que d'ailleurs c'est fractures
enfouies elles sont toujours actives
c'est de montrer que bah l'Ukraine si on
prend ce fil rouge du du cultuel des
religions
il existe ce pays comme nation
contrairement à ce que dit Poutine les
Poutine est un négationniste n'est-ce
pas et un révisionniste il faut pas
écouter ce que dit Poutine ce pays il
existe parce que évidemment c'est un
agrégat de peuple de culture de culte
détenus un long agrégat mais il y a
quelque chose qui caractérise cette
nation ukrainienne qui existe du
indépendant indépendante elle existe du
neuvième ou 12e siècle puis elle essaie
d'exister au 16e 17e siècle il y a
toujours attrapé puis en 1917 elle ne
croit s'émanciper l'Empire ça risque
d'être rattrapé par l'Union soviétique
dès 1991 les Ukrainiens quel que soit
leurs origines leur sensibilité se
prononce unanimement pour l'indépendance
pourquoi parce qu'il y a une sociabilité
ukrainienne
méridionale pastorale c'est une
sociabilité d'ailleurs assez
démocratique parce que c'est l'assemblée
villageoise n'est-ce pas etc et ça ça se
distingue totalement du générus qui est
un génie convulsif qui est un génie
impératif qui est peut-être certaine
Eugénie torturé il y a une forme de
bonheur ukrainien d'ailleurs un crime de
plus évidemment de Poutine c'est de
vouloir
anéantir ce bonheur ukrainien d'être
encore une fois au dessin vous voyez il
faut penser un peu à Marseille vous êtes
absolument sans appel sur sur Poutine
sur son projet de mort vous parlez d'un
régime totalitaire et les Russes les
Russes cette société que vous connaissez
si bien qu'il biberonent à la propagande
qui soutient massivement faut quand même
le dire son chef alors
si vous voulez on a on a vu dans ce beau
reportage le patriarche qui rit le
patriaryl ça n'est pas l'orthodoxie et
Poutine ça n'est pas la Russie n'est-ce
pas Poutine et Kiril sont les alliés
d'un régime qui est fondé sur en fait la
victoire des total des services secrets
qui a tourné à l'oligarchie cleptomane
donc on est face à une mafia et et qui
rime n'est pas un homme religieux abusé
par un tyran il est un pivot de ce
système ce parrain de ce système au sens
mafieux c'est Poutine mais il y a tout
un système mafieux auto
alors ce système mafieux a prié les
Russes de leur mémoire Poutine a fermé
mémorial grande fondation qui essayait
de collecter les archives du Goulag pour
que les Russes comprennent ce que leur
est arrivé bon il a fermé quelques jours
avant l'évasion de l'Ukraine parce qu'il
fallait effectivement faire taire le
travail sur les crimes d'hier pour
pouvoir accomplir les crimes
d'aujourd'hui
Poutine en fait à lobotomiser la société
russe et pourtant même lobotomiser voyez
que en fait il y a des forces vives
extraordinaires culturelles elles sont
en exiles ou en prison vous avez vu tous
ces gamins sur les routes qui refusent
de faire la guerre à jésus-chriniens qui
restent pour des frères même si les
ukrainien ne veulent plus entendre
parler des Russes je crois qu'on est
face à une expression du mal radical
Poutine nous montre que nous n'avons pas
soldé nos comptes avec le totalitarisme
nous l'avons un peu trop vite oublié
merci
merci beaucoup Jean-François colossimo
la crucifixion de l'Ukraine c'est à dire
chez Albin Michel Milan de guerre de
religion en Europe et c'est absolument
passionnant pour comprendre l'histoire
et surtout les origines de ce conflit
vous restez avec moi si vous voulez bien
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur partie prix sont
deux ce soir un nouveau visage on
accueille l'avocat Bertrand Perrier
grand spécialiste de l'art oratoire qui
va devenir sur cette histoire de
nouveaux pays un nouveau pays de listes
tambour qui enflammé Twitter et puis
Yanis roder prof d'histoire-géo et ces
histoires d'école ce soir le 49.3
expliqué au collégien bonsoir les
affranchis et bonsoir Bertrand Perrier
on est ravi de vous avoir parmi nous
c'est très agréable de se dire que vous
allez faire partie de notre petite
famille sur LCP alors vous nous parlez
ce soir de l'actualité de Twitter en
lien avec d'ailleurs votre votre dernier
livre sur le débat le débat politique
mais pas seulement le débat citoyen avec
tout d'abord un littéralement enflammé
la toile depuis dimanche la création de
toutes pièces d'un nouvel état et oui
Myriam c'était dimanche dernier et un
utilisateur de Twitter du nom de
gaspardo a posté un message qui était
destiné à se moquer de la prétendue
nullité légendaire des Américains en
matière de géographie et donc ce message
était je suis sûr que les Américains ne
connaissent même pas le nom de ce pays
et on voyait donc cette carte que vous
montrez avec un état qui se situerait au
bout de la péninsule ibérique et qui
s'appellerait donc le l'Istanbul le
tweet est devenu viral et tout le monde
a embrayé sur cette blague potache et
donc des livres ou à assurer l'ivré au
listambour Free a expliqué que le
listambour était compris dans le forfait
et le site de Jo Paris 2024 a accueilli
les athlètes l'istan bourgeois et leur a
souhaité la bienvenue évidemment les
internautes ont pris le relais et le
listambour s'est vu doté d'une histoire
de paysages évidemment totalement fictif
d'une justice d'un et puis évidemment
les politiques s'y sont mis et c'est
ainsi qu'Olivier fort a proclamé l'Union
des socialistes français je cite avec
nos camarades istanbourgeois pour une
Europe sociale et écologique Jean
Lassalle a raconté sa visite au salon de
l'agriculture du Istanbul avec photo et
ici même à l'Assemblée nationale Jérôme
Guedj a saisi la présidente Yaël Braun
Pivet de la création d'un groupe
d'amitié France
Istanbul alors qu'est-ce que ça révèle
selon vous de Twitter et est-ce qu'il
faut se réjouir de cet épisode là ou pas
bah c'est assez potache et assez amusant
ça a été un petit jeu pendant 24 heures
ou 48 heures malgré tout plus
profondément je crois que ça révèle deux
choses la puissance du réseau Twitter et
puis son côté un peu facétieux
irrévérencieux la puissance de Twitter
elle tient en deux chiffres
250 millions d'utilisateurs quotidiens
près de 10 000 tweets par seconde et oui
le caractère irrévérencieux c'est un peu
ce qui est au cœur de la la seconde
actualité de la semaine de Twitter c'est
à dire quid de cette liberté après le
rachat finalisé la semaine dernière par
Elon Musk
pour 44 milliards de dollars par un
souci de faire prévaloir sa vision
extensive de la liberté d'expression oui
c'est ce qui résulte du premier tweet
qui l'a publié après la finalisation du
rachat de la semaine dernière on le
souvient de bird is freed de Bird c'est
le symbole de Twitter il fuite
c'est-à-dire et libérer et ce qui a
provoqué évidemment la réaction de
Thierry Breton le commissaire européen
qui a tout de suite dit le l'oiseau ne
volera que selon nos règles c'est-à-dire
les règles de la concurrence européenne
et donc on a une sorte de bras de fer
qui s'engage entre ceux plutôt dans le
camp conservateur qui se réjouissent du
rachat de Twitter par Elon Musk qui
mettrait fin à ce qu'il considère comme
une censure sur Twitter dont évidemment
l'éviction de Donald Trump aurait été le
symbole et puis de l'autre côté ceux qui
s'inquiète d'un trop grand relâchement
de la modération
sur Twitter est une moindre vigilance
sur la haine en ligne dernier
rebondissement Elon Musk a annoncé
vouloir faire payer les comptes
certifiés et oui 8 euros par mois c'est
le prix qu'il faudrait mettre pour avoir
la petite pastille bleue sur son compte
alors Bruno Le Maire a réagi et a déjà
dit que il paierait mais que ça lui
ferait mal moi ce que je crois c'est que
ça révèle quelque chose d'assez
préoccupant c'est à dire la truite au
dépendances de nos hommes politiques
pourquoi est-ce que les hommes
politiques pour leur communication y
compris publique ce sont laissés mettre
dans une dépendance à l'égard d'un
réseau purement privé et donc il y a une
sorte de retour de bâton puisque twitter
fait bien ce qu'il veut avec les hommes
politiques il les bannit il les soumet à
des règles et je crois que ce retour de
bâton fait que ils n'ont aujourd'hui et
d'autres choix que de s'incliner
derrière devant les risques du nouveau
Twitter devant ses règles là partout
sauf peut-être au Istanbul merci quelle
chut merci beaucoup Bertrand vous vous
êtes accro Twitter pas vraiment
pas du tout non
félicitations
à la bêtise c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
est accro à Twitter on finit toujours
par dire que quelque chose qui au fond
des passes à penser et après il faut
s'en justifier face à des millions
d'anonymes qui vous promettent d'être
crucifié
à enseigner juste avant la Toussaint et
les vacances 49.3 à ses collégiens
qu'est-ce que ça donne
mes élèves m'ont demandé de leur
expliquer le 49-3 et pour tout vous dire
j'ai un peu ramé alors pourquoi
racontez-nous tout ça c'est en fait
c'est ça peut être un peu rébarbatif les
49-3 imaginez plutôt alors le 49.3 c'est
un article de la Constitution tout le
monde se souvient de ce qu'est la
Constitution non bon donc un outil qui
permet de se passer du vote du Parlement
le Parlement c'est bon c'est non c'est
pas bon parce que le gouvernement ne
dispose pas d'une majorité à l'Assemblée
nationale une majorité de quoi oui
évidemment et il peut donc utiliser cet
article mais un nombre limité de fois
pour faire passer son texte de loi voilà
donc c'était pas facile je vous laisse
deviner l'engouement de mes élèves pour
mes explications pas évident donc c'est
nécessaire pourtant c'est très important
de faire comprendre le fonctionnement
nos instituts absolument nécessaire au
regard de ce que nous dit aujourd'hui la
jeunesse française de son engagement
citoyen jugé plutôt 71% des 18 24 ans ne
sont pas allés voter aux législatif 51%
des jeunes ont choisi un parti
contestataire au présidentiel à gauche
ou à droite 63% pense que la démocratie
directe est le meilleur des systèmes et
last but 19% sont admiratifs de Vladimir
Poutine ce ne sont que quelques chiffres
tirés de différentes enquêtes mais qui
nous montrent que là nous avons une
vraie question alors d'où vient ce
divorce finalement vis-à-vis de la chose
publique c'est la faute des enseignants
non les enseignants font le travail ces
institutions et leurs fonctionnements
Myriam s'entrent dans une histoire il
faut donc expliquer d'où elles viennent
ces institutions et pourquoi elles
existent en un mot il faut parvenir à
donner du sens au modèle républicain et
démocratique comment con je n'ai pas de
recette miracle Myriam mais vous savez
on a parfois du mal à apprécier ce qu'on
possède surtout si on ne parvient pas à
le mettre en perspective avec le passé
ni si on ignore ce qu'il se passe
ailleurs il est évident que si on se
contente d'annonner un catéchisme
républicain et égrainer les institutions
les unes après les autres et leur
fonctionnement je vous mets au défi de
rendre sexy dans la République en
revanche si vous parlez de projets
politiques propres à une société humaine
qui s'est construite au fil du temps
traversant des étapes vers plus de
liberté vers plus d'égalité vous donner
du sens à ce qu'il te passe au Parlement
mais aussi au concept de nation de
République de démocratie d'autre part
vous savez je me suis aperçu que les
élèves ne sont jamais autant intéressés
que quand ils découvrent par
l'intermédiaire d'articles de presse par
exemple comment cela se passe ailleurs
aussi bien en termes de fonctionnement
politique qu'en terme de respect des
valeurs et des droits de l'homme je me
souviens d'un élève qui m'a dit c'est
bien la France en fait oui c'est bien
mais tout cela prend du temps et
l'enseignement moral est civique dans
lequel s'inscrivent ces cours et souvent
le parent pauvre et une variable
justement vous le faites quand vous avez
le temps en fait pourtant il devrait
matière à le rendre vivant cet
enseignement et intéressant en
l’insérant dans l'histoire et dans le
présent ce que font déjà nombreux
d'enseignants évidemment mais il manque
de temps car les programmes sont trop
lourds et la pédagogie demande de
répéter et de répéter encore regardez
chiffres de l'abstention il me semble
qu'il va falloir se pencher sérieusement
sur cette question merci merci beaucoup
Yanis vous avez enseigné Jean-François
colissimo oui mais
dans un cadre universitaire la théologie
par universitaire privée puisqu'en
France la théologie ne fait pas partie
des matières à enseigner sauf sauf à
Strasbourg n'est-ce pas et en territoire
mais ce sont les théologies catholiques
et protestantes et moi matthologie est
orthodoxe donc
ça a été privé vos étudiants étaient
déjà à vos élèves très érudits et ils
devaient connaître le 49-3 merci merci
beaucoup les accrochis la crucifixion de
l'Ukraine chez Albin Michel Milan de
guerre de religion en Europe pour
comprendre les origines d'où vient ce
conflit en Ukraine merci à vous très
belle soirée documentaire qui commence
maintenant et Jean-Pierre graffien bien
sûr à demain même mieux même heure
[Musique]